[Musica]
l'altro giorno una mamma mi scrive la vj
perché non fai dei video più educativi
per i ragazzi mentre l a tutti ragazzi e
vengono da questo video sono fa vj e
oggi ci tireremmo gli schiaffi completo
quindi venuta in mente questa cosa
perché la trota ho fatto vito consoli
dove lo schiaffo era leggero oggi
giochiamo a schiaffi seri quindi ogni
volta che una persona sbaglia sul gioco
in questo caso hiver lower l'altro le
feature di schiaffo ok regola non parli
di zipper regole chi arriva a 10 dallo
schiaffo all'altro cioè allora ok ok se
tu sbagli tipica uno schiaffo se vuoi
rivederci melone ok inizio io bike tra
camera e mi del march micam la fiera d
occhio al midem marce kenny rogers eni
rogers all'e3 scena voglia bene
sudando foresta di londra perché ho
tradotto in italiano nottingham forest
air foresta di nottingham ho tradotto in
italiano siete la tradotto malissimo
nottingham forest ai rischi dai sbaglia
egitto al prestigio editto egitto
no si tratta mila die die teatro
dell'opera di sydney di più o di kakà ma
no non possiamo partire manchester al
mare che cazzo è sentito mano che arriva
all'ora
ap il cervello agli allora ho riletto e
la matica dai real madrid pensano alla
fine e dolci sono migliaia 12 milioni
della di chiusura banner migliore in
breve la tv prima da marotta sono gli
artigiani è una traduzione fatta male
savaia più nero bene se a 4 rugby union
è una squadra ne avrà 70 mi son forti 80
mese squadra di rugby che non si caga
nessuno e grano perché ben 60.000 io ti
giuro in questo gioco non sono ma perché
rischia fino nido non sono capaci
richino fi nei video che vedo che i
ragazzi mi piace fare i festivi
non è vero mi piacciono quando l'ex
squalo o islam
chi sbaglia la prima doppio fortissimo
noto poi dopo pochissimo ai l'ansia ai
l'ansia non solo inculano l'islam was
found it might quindi prevedo che scappi
io mi scappi stai fermo e mi piace
questo vita stai fermo aspetta anche
labardi bella questa
no poi stimato gli altri sono bravo però
fallo e liszt a rinunciarvi volontà
stare ma che non lascio lassú ok due
ducati solo in questo modo duro e
corporeo o risultati del calcio non
preme no bergamo un milione e il
giardino segreto non avrà di meno
giardini a sacre dello scatto
il calma
10 piramide si farà come di me non
l'avrei mai detto né anch'io te lo giuro
[Musica]
disney.com giusta noi no
venere o a rampe valeeva venere da yo ma
porca [ __ ] è di essere l'uomo giusto
possiamo essere stati presi io rimango
la cosa aspetta e non scappo fatto video
animati con altoparlanti attività al
pezzo di merda è un paio sempre stati ma
porca [ __ ] open o austria
allora non dovevo salire brivido su
george foreman nono diminuendo ma ne
subisce la figura della madre il quale
su le zebre da 50.000 sempre dna di
problema c'è ma che domande di merda a
me l'islam
lo squalo vero c'è la porta e la
tennista superfamosa ma non so se la più
o meno di viene meno anche per ringrazia
che non una racchetta per davide vaira
che non è facile farlo cioè mi sento
proprio per me è facilissimo basta del
mali aspetti facile voglio far vedere
una roba non aspettata facciale in
diretta mondiali d'ischia così esistono
i cantieri marziali ma sì sì slap
contest guarda guarda guarda che se l'è
meritata
queste sono lette da da ogni no così che
so che trovavo lì che svengono arrivato
ed è ancora cioè vince chi rimane in
piedi ti rendi conto perché si fa
necessità ma non solo sentir tre giorni
due morto la semi sta morendo
probabilmente vecchia dietro la vecchia
capire il bambino con l'hiv
porca vacca che sveglia hai visto video
e gli schiaffi che siano preparate per
chiamare difficile puntato è facilissimo
visto settore senso di più o di meno
green bay packers chi cazzo sono loro le
500 dubai
beh dai guai dubai the road il brillante
un film non sarà inferiore grande anche
tantissimo e convinto più di 100.000
blake fish inferiore ma chi sale in cura
le orche ac milan balotelli tra l'altro
è nuova a questo e altro che se nuova
serie a è famosissimo e famosissima per
o meno grande set polizia di più grande
colonia grande polizia meccanico ma
quanta gente si sparerà la macchina però
di meglio dire che noi meccanico su
internet in 450 oscar wilde oscar wilde
non vale team a stranger things hawks
oscar mai facciamo l'ultima perché è
parità tra cui tre già tings regioni
domandona pavin i patti per il veloce
dai forza di spaccio due rondò e
disfacevano visto quindi bisogna cercare
moda e vai propiano è quando ti sei
divorando il cuscino più violento del
mondo si scherza sei morto i veri uomini
un pochino guardati fa malissimo proprio
scemo si può privare veramente che ha
visto ho fatto uscire i metadati
poverissima triumph amarissimo davvero
ma scopro che sia possibile non è giusto
cassetti che due ostacoli che fa peggio
di uno schiaffo e per il 1 signor prego
il bel agosto e lo ha fatto adesso io
allora gli ultimi 21 a lampard riparte
ridge che consuma e cazzo ne so grazie
ad essa bradley cooper signore ma grandi
fughe in avanti di mera di più bradley
cooper
ok via veneto sei stato armas starbucks
7.500.000 black eyed peas
basta le nostre 4 mila o stai fermo giri
prima stata né vedere né che mi cambio
da circa 50 centesimi
era bellissimo momento che siamo anche
riusciti senza siamo di 16 o cena più la
scusa sono un miliardo di persone
la clio ed ho potuti capitale cerchi il
nonno senso che io no 550 attenzioni ma
con due madrid atletico attenzione
l'ultima loro prima mickey è difficile
questa chi vince di noi due adesso
quindi se sbaglio vento giusto vinto io
tira lo schiaffo istantanea
basta basta basta basta io credo che
onestamente tra tutti i video che ho
fatto questo sia il più ignorante però
dal video che ho fatto con surreal power
dove lo schiaffo era questo mai più la
presa più stupida che abbia mai fatto
male non fatelo a casa che tanto non ha
senso in rete un video per gli haters
pensa non contenti gli haters un sacco
che ho fatto per voi per noi ammazzano
schiaffo da joker e da ciccio che gioca
massimo videogiochi del ciccio gamer
gara di schiaffi legame ciccio generate
gioca
però io questo video vi sia piaciuto
comunque il cuscino 2 giuro che fa male
non so perché è una foratura o per
averci aiutato ma senza di me piace un
momento mi piace anche ora i soci ha
commentato descrizione sapore si rischia
temi ci vediamo un prossimo video e poi
magari con arrivo di profondità
guarda il cuscino rosso minchia ma non
so perché basta qui è mai ti giuro
cuscino non so perché facciamoci male
[Musica]